Jealousy is a strong burning emotion filled
with lots of nuances.
The thing is, when it comes to jealousy there
is one place where straight men stand alone.
Evolutionary psychology is kind of weird.
It's a bunch of highly educated scientists
looking at modern humans and applying Darwin's
evolutionary principles to behaviors they
observe.
While there IS research involved, it's kind
of like educated guessing.
We can't go back in time and see exactly what
prompted the adaptation that resulted in jealousy,
but evolutionary psychologists can test how
it works now and guess[1]!
For the people who've never experienced jealousy
-- to which I personally say, "what?!"
-- jealousy has its roots in envy, suspicion,
mistrust, anxiety and protective possession.
It's usually attributed to relationships,
and feels like a burning all encompassing
emotive mess.
A hot friggin' mess[2][3].
Evolutionary psychologists say this feeling
has been part of humanity for a million years,
evolving when humans were still living solely
in Africa.
Males were constantly guarding the social
group and providing food while the females
were maintaining social structure and raising
the offspring.
According to their hypothesis, male jealousy
evolved to ensure they weren't providing resources
to mates who weren't prioritizing their genes
-- i.e. females who were thirsty for their
sidepiece[4].
On the other hand female jealousy, though
originating from the same inner structures,
manifested as anxiety over emotional betrayal
because her mate might split the hunting spoils
with HIS sidepiece!
That meant fewer resources for her and the
offspring.
Jealousy burns hotly in both men and women,
but the cause is slightly different.
It all sounds very… tweet-drama like, and
yet, studies over the years have confirmed
male and female jealousy do work in this way!
Now a new study in the Archives of Sexual
Behavior, the largest ever completed, claims
they've confirmed yet again how jealousy works.
In this giant study of 64,000 Americans[5],[6],
they found that when it comes to sexual infidelity,
straight men are the most heated.
Heterosexual men cannot abide when their partner
has physical relations with another.
That being said, straight women, gay, lesbian,
and bisexual men AND women were ALL more concerned
by emotional infidelity[7] -- or the idea
that their partner might love someone else.
The lead researcher wanted to learn what the
largest triggers of jealousy might be, and
for whom those triggers are strongest; and
it turns out only heterosexual men are NOT
worried about their partner falling in love
with another person.
Of course, it also depends on how you ask
participants the questions in a study like
this.
An older study out of Northeastern[8] found
when presented with seven different types
of infidelity, rather than simply emotional
or physical, the differences between the sexes
(at least) shrank.
What about you?
What would send you into a jealous rage?